you might have thought that an island
nation hundreds of miles away from any
land mass would have been a reassuringly
safe place to be in recent weeks but in
that time the mesmerizing beauty of the
so called Land of Fire and Ice enticed
in plenty of visitors ice lenders
themselves headed in and out for work
and pleasure in a world of mass travel
remoteness is no insurance against a
virus spread by people and yet this
small nation hit back against the
arrival of Co vid with a strategy of
test test test and unusually not just on
the sick but the seemingly healthy not a
single person in this busy private
clinic has shown the faintest sign of
having the virus but they've turned up
anyway to be tested for reassurance to
make sure they don't spread disease
unwittingly and to provide blood for
research into antibodies to fight covert
and I want to be safe if I'm gonna have
ants for tomorrow and it's yes oh so I
have to stay home as part of our social
responsibility I feel responsibility to
come and just do the test to make sure
that me and the people I live with like
um virus free Iseman now believes it is
tested a higher percentage of people
than any other nation more than 45,000
samples have been taken from a
population of just three hundred and
sixty thousand over forty percent of
those who tested positive had no
symptoms at the time and were quickly
isolated the country's prime minister
admits being a small nation has its
advantages but they're keen to share
what they've learned with the world in a
small country people really it's it's
easier to get information to everybody
and I think we have shown a lot of
solidarity also and that's very
Icelandic maybe because we're a small
nation on an island and we tend to argue
about everything but when we are really
hit with something difficult we tend to
show very strong solidarity and we've
been doing that the
testing is only part of Iceland success
story which has seen the number of cases
dropped to a daily handful on one day
recently none at all huge effort has
gone into tracking contacts of people
confirmed to be infected Detective Chief
Inspector guest de Parma s'en is part of
a tracing team which at one point was a
hundred and sixty strong a veteran of
counterterrorism and organized crime
he's using old-fashioned investigative
skills to locate people who've been
close to those who tested positive the
phone app which can trace where people
have been is now helping in that effort
the rule of thumb is if you've been
within law within 2 metres for more than
15 minutes of an individual he is
believed to you're believed to be a
contact so once we've gathered all your
contacts we call the contacts and tell
them that they have to go into
quarantine for two weeks
Iceman's approach of test track and
isolate has allowed it to avoid some of
the more draconian restrictions imposed
by other nations but the government has
now decided anyone entering the country
passed a quarantine believing they've
got on top of the virus they don't want
to risk travellers spreading it again
Michelle Clifford Sky News rekka vaq
Iceland